the most profound issue we are dealing
with here today as the fundamental
divide between Washington and the
American people there is a ruling class
in Washington DC that believes they are
subjected to different rules than the
American people that it's perfectly
appropriate for political friends and
allies of the President to get
exemptions while single moms and young
people and Hispanics and African
Americans the people struggling union
workers struggling to pay the bills
provide for their kids they don't get an
exemption the difference with green eggs
and ham
is when Americans tried it they
discovered they did not like green eggs
and ham and they did not like Obamacare
either they did not like Obamacare in a
box with a fox in a house or with a
mouse people are frustrated because
their elected officials don't listen
when we're home on the campaign trail we
say we listen and yet something about
this Senate floor something about
Washington DC other if it's the water
something in the air the cherry blossoms
but people get here and they stop
listening to the American people